ما يهمني
رقص ماليه والاشتراكيه ما يهمني تدخل
الحكومه ولا ما تتدخل انا كحكومه ابنها
خلني اسوي اللعبه انا عندي الهم اني اخلي
حياه المواطن كريم
هذه ترى كلمه الرئيس الصيني اول رئيس جاء
بعد معه
يوم انه انت بتحط سياسات راس ماليه
وكيف تسمح هذا الشيء يصير قال ما يهم
وشلون القط والفار
بس اذا اذا احنا اتكلم على شيء مستدام
لن يكون هذا الشيء يعني يقدم الرفاهيه او
يقدم مستوى افضل المواطنين علامه الطويل
فجرف انه يكون في تحكم كامل بالاقتصاد
لعقود ما ادى الى انتاجيه كان في يعني
مجاعات ومصايب
هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن ابو
مالح ادري ان المواضيع الاقتصاديه تؤثر في
كل شيء في حياتنا يا ابني على اساسها
السياسي قراراته يتحرك التاجر معها ويتاثر
المواطن والمقيم منها سواء في السكن او في
الصحه او الاكل كل شيء في حياتك يعتمد
بشكل او اخر على فكره اقتصاديه ولان هذا
مهم جدا هذه الحلقه مهمه لو اضع عنوان
لهذه الحلقه اعتقد بيكون ما هو الدور
المثالي للحكومه متى تتدخل الحكومه في
الاقتصاد كيف اثرت تشريعات وكثرتها على
الاقتصاد في السعوديه مثلا الحكومه تتدخل
في نوع الزيت اللي تطبخ فيه البرجر وماذا
تلبس اذا كنت تشتغل فيه
والحكومات ممكن
تؤثر بشكل اخر على غير تشريعات اللي هو
انشاء شركات حكوميه وهنا زي التشريعات
تنفصل الناس بين راي مؤيد وراي معاده
الشركات الحكوميه مثلا سابكو ارامكو
الاولى دخلها اكثر من بعض الدول الثانيه
الاهرام
الماضي كانت اغلى شركه في العالم هذه
امثله ناجحه جدا ممكن يكون لانها طبعا
شركه نفطيه او معتمد على النفط لكن برده
في دول غنيه نفطيه وفقيره جدا وهنا الجزء
الثالث هو كيف تصنع الدول قيمه الاقتصاديه
ما هو دور الحكومات في جعلتها غنيه بغض
النظر عن ثروات الطبيعيه همم كوريا
الجنوبيه سنغافوره فقيره من الثروات
الطبيعيه لكنها غنيه جدا
والعراق وليبيا ونيوزلندا وايران واوغندا
وغيرها اغنيه جدا من النفط سنوات الطبيعيه
ومعظم شعوبها يعيش تحت خط الفقر هذه
المواضيع المعقده والمهمه جدا ضيفي قادر
على شرحها باسلوب قصصي بديع ضيفي محمد سعد
الجابر المهتم في مواضيع الاعمال
والاقتصاد قبل ان نبدا سلكنا اسماء
لضيوف او مواضيع تقترحونها على بريد
البرنامج
دوت كوم
الان
ايش رايك تغيير اسم القهوه السعوديه
يمديك تاخذها من اكثر
عربيه فهي بالنسبه للجزيره العربيه
اكبر بقعه جغرافيه تقدم فيها القهوه بهذا
الشكل في السعوديه
البطن
بس
الى الى اي متى بيكون اقتصاديه
انا ضعيف الله ههه
شكل
لانه الناس شويه تستغرب من
موضوع
ليش مثلا القهوه عندنا بصير غاليه ومنها
غاليه الحين هل باقل سعرها
بعد
سبب بحكم انه ما عندك كميات تجاريه ضخمه
ما تقدر تنافس بالكامل
بتشوف مثلا
اي دوله
دخلها عالي مساحتها صغيره
للصناعات التخصصيات اكثر ممكن اوضح بثلاثه
فبينما الدول اللي
كبيره عندها خيرات اكبر طبعا ممكن يكون
فيه اشياء خاصيه لكن تقدر تنافس في اشياء
في الزراعه عندنا مساحه الزراعيه كبيره
باسم مقارنه الدول العربيه
لكن نطلع الى مثلا زي البرازيل او في
انتاج القهوه مستحيل مساحات ضخمه جدا
فمنطقي انا بكون سعرها عالي وهذا هذا
القرار الاسلم اصلا المزارع
يختار اعلى الاصناف وتهتم زوجتها
مشاركه في مزادات الى اخره
المعيار جودتها
والمكان حقها والقصه حقها يعني اكثر
والهويه في هويه في جانب همم يعني تسويقي
عظيم بصراحه
اظن بريطانيا
قبل خمس سنوات او اربع سنوات المشكله
ثلاث اربع مليون مشاهدات بسيطه همم بعدين
رجع وسافر
مطار دخلتها بحياتي ههه
فرجع لهم في همم في رحله قبل شهرين وممم
يعني
وانبساط صراحه لانه همم كتحسن في الاداء
هو هو يقول ان هذا افضل طيران يعني شفت
حسن همم بس العوده على القهوه انه كان في
همم انه اعطاه قهوه في البدايه
في اشياء كثيره في التجربه تقدر تحسنها
متكرره يعني
بس القهوه العربيه
مميزه فتعطيك هويه او استقلاليه
يعني بدون يعني كيف تقدر تكبر يعني هو
مكان
بيدخلني على سالفه التدخل يعني كيف تقدر
تكبر او انك تقدم القهوه يعني انت عندك
مكان تقدر تستثمر تقدر تطلع منها فلوس
تقدر تفيد يعني عوائد اقتصادي كثير
وانت عندك القصه الاساسيه للقهوه القهوه
القهوه
ولا هي صناعه صعبه
طبعا وضع دول الخلي الخليج في الوقت
الحالي شوي استثنائيه لكن مثال
ليش ترك يعني قطاع مثل القهوه او في
قطاعات زراعيه اخرى تركه
لانه صار فيه دخل بديل ودخل جدا عالي
فالزراعه يعني حتى لو فيها ربح بس اربح
100 ولا 4000
دخل النفط اللي اللي هو يخلق هيكل
الاقتصاد ما هو الطبيعي ماهو يعني هو
الاستاندر بالموجود
فيخلي القطاعات الثانيه تفقد الجدوها
هذا الشيء يعني فريد في الوقت الحالي بس
في اوقات مختلفه على مر التاريخ دول مره
في نفس المشاكل في هولندا صناعات كثيره
ماتت وقت وقت صلاه النفط والغاز دخلت
عندهم همم
يمكن 300 400 سنه وقت الاستعمار الاسباني
لجنوب امريكا همم
يحصلون على على كميه ضخمه من الفضه ودخلت
عندهم في همم في الاقتصاد والناس صاروا
يروحون يشتغلون
كنود او موظفين الحكومه هسه صلاح
فاضطروا انهم يجيبون خياطين ويجيبون يعني
طباخين ومن دول اوروبا الثانيه
المشكله دائما اذا جينا نكون انه ما في
جدول
فالحكومه تتدخل اصلا عدم وجود الجدول جزء
منه انه كان في تدخل خارجي في السوق
فلول صناعه النفط ما كانت موجوده
لا ما راح نطلع
الدوله لكن هذا الواقع هذا
السبب اذا اذا محتاج نفهم انه ليش فصلنا
همم
صناعه النفط خلقت لنا اقتصاد غير اعتيادي
فاكيد انه في صناعات اقل ربحيه راح تبقى
جدها الان احنا في مرحله همم احنا نستقل
معناها موجوده بس ما تتحكم فينا ما تتحكم
في اقتصادي
وسير في استقلاليه
اغتصاب فاللي افهمه
دخوله هو محاوله نحنا نسوي همم هبوط همم
همم
اخذنا نقول همم ناعم يعني سوفت لانك فلو
صار انه في دخل النفط والناس معتمده على
الوظائف الحكوميه معتمده على الدعم ثم
فجاه نقول نبغى نسوي نفس النموذجيه نطلع
الفلوس ونخليها استثمارات خارجيه ما تخلي
اقتصاد
والشركه
همم انت عندك صناعات ماتت من 10 سنوات
همم معرفه راحت هو اصلا حتى لو معرفه
موجوده وهي معرفه في وقت قديم الصناعه في
العالم الان تغيرت
افهم محاوله احنا نسوي هبوط ناعم في
الاقتصاد احنا نرجع على رتب الطبيعي بس
المعارضه
المبدا من واضح انه في مرحله معينه الناس
معتقده انه لا هذا هو النموذج الافضل
في القهوه
الطرح كله موجود على تمكين قطاع الخاص همم
سياسه صندوق استثمارات تغيرت اصلا صار
الدخول في قطاعات همم قطعه جديده قطاعات
ما فيها يعني همم يعني منافسه عاليه
والخروج منها
اذا صار فيه
بدا صدوق كبير اجسام الشركات السوق الاسود
الفهم من جهه ال ال الحكومه موجود انه
الدور ما هو بالانتاج لكن مباشر هل هذا
شيء يطبق في كل الشركات في كل الجهات
الحكوميه لا يعني ااا احنا نعتقد انه
يعني في نظره معينه بتطبق 100% على جميع
هيك الكبير اتكلم على ملايين اشتراك في
الحكومه في قطاعات مختلفه
فبتتحصل مثلا في بلديه في مكان مع راح
دخله يفتحون اكشاكرون
نحن نبغى داخل
والنافس مع انه موهوب وش الشيء اللي يضيف
قيمه للمكان اللي انت فيها يعني
حتى لو كان في على مستوى عالي نظره معينه
واش دوره الحكومه في الاقتصاد انا احيانا
على بعض المستويات ما تصير النظره هذه
موجوده وهامه الناس اا
برضه يعني يشوفون
يشوفون تجارب اللي موجوده قدامهم الان
ناجحه
وتوقعونها بتنجح في في جميع التطبيقات همم
فيشوفوا مثلا والله همم في شركات همم بدات
شركه علوي مقدمه خدماتهم ممتازه وسهله همم
طيب بس ما يشوف الامثله اللي كانت فيها
شركه تبع الدوله همم وكان اداء موهم جيد
والحكومه طرت انها تبيع الاصول او تطلع
احنا الان في موجود تخصصه رقم اثنين يعني
في موجه كانت الالفيه في ال 2001 2002
شركه اتصالات كان في توجه حتى على على
قطاع اكبر من ضمنها الطيران همم
ونفس الملفات اللي كانت موجوده على
التحليه صوامع الغلال كل القطاعات هذه
يعني ما تم خصصتها فداك الوقت الان رجعت
على الطاوله انه نبغى ااا نخصصها
فالدور الحكومه في الاقتصاد لازم شكل
خلينا نكون تنظيري يصير واضح انه
تنظيم تشريع رسم سياسات عامه همم
وتدخل يكون في المجال العام فاكيد في
خدمات عامه همم او مثلا في الامن همم ابن
المسيره الخارجيه الى اخره هذه وجود
الدوله في السوق في الاقتصاد تحديدا همم
لا منظمه مشرع همم طيب ايش اللي نفهم
والانف في السياق مثلا الشركات اللي
موجوده تدخل في السوق همم بعضها زي اللي
ذكرته انه محاوله ان احنا نرجع همم تدرج
همم
فهو تدخل وقتي همم وبعضها لا ما هو منطقي
يعني كنت تدخل في اسواق فيها ناس موجوده
همم العائق من تطورها كانت تنظيم
طيب انا قبل استحضر اكثر محليه خلنا نشوف
لنفس نفس نفس الممارسه الموجوده في الدول
ثانيه
انا بدي اتكلم على دوله تشيلي دوله تشيلي
في امريكا الجنوبيه اااه دوله يعني ما هو
مكان استراتيجي او عندهم اي شيء مميز
الدوله عاشت فتره يمكن حوالي 50 سنه في
تقلبات بس اغلبها كان اتجاه اشتراك اكثر
همم
فبدا من توسع الحكومه في تقديم الخدمات
الى انه تم تاميم همم
تنقيب عن المعادن همم بعدين دخله في حتى
يعني شيوعيه تامه في السبعينات
همم انه ما عاد في اسواق ما عاد في ملكيه
خاصه كل المحلات التجاريه ترجع للدوله
التسعير من عند الدوله يعني صارت الشيوعيه
تامه
ما طول الوضع هذا لانه كان في ازمه
اقتصاديه ما بدات بسبب هذا الشيء تحديدا
لها فتره طويله من تراكمه بس
وجود الشيوعيين كانوا هو المحاوله الناس
الاخيره انه نبغى اي حال يعني خلي الدوله
المملكه
الوضع خلال سنتين ثلاث سنوات صار يعني
سيء جدا
فصار في انقلاب
همم والسياسه تغيرت مع الحكومه الجديده
همم
حصل عاد في قصه جانبيه
فرق الوقت
في جامعه في في سانتياغو اللي هي العاصمه
الجامعه هذه كان عندها تعاقد على ارسال
بعثات من من تشيلي الى امريكا وتحديدا في
جامعه شيكاغو
والغريب انه جزء من الطلاب كان يدرسون ضد
السعوديه
في الطلاب كانوا يحضرون رساله الدكتوراه
صادق امريكي مشهور ومن احد المشجعين همم
السوق الحر
عدد كبير من الطلاب ملتشيلي تحديدا درسوا
تحت يد من ورجعهم يوم حصل الازمه في
السبعينات تغيرت الحكومه
مع وجود الحكومه الجديده
طبعا في حديث انه الله وصولها اصلا كان
بمساعده من السي اي اي الى اخره لكن نحيد
الجانب السياسي همم ما كان في يعني
ايديولوجيا واضحه كيف نطير وكان في همم
لازال اصوات معينه اشتراكيه همم احنا نخفف
شوي من القيود على السوق بس ما نطلع منه
همم بس همم تحت الضغط انه الوضع جدا سيئ
قام اضطر ان همم يروح يتكلم الجامعه
اعطوني ناس في الاقتصادي يجون
نتكلم معهم جو المجموعه هذه الطلاب عند
همم دكاتره وقتها عند من
وراسهم ولا سياسه اقتصاديه ومسكهم همم
تشريعات وحتى مناصب تنفيذيه في الدوله همم
واللي هو يطلق عليهم بعدين انشقاقه بويز
طبعا القصه لها برده جانب خارجي همم
يوم يوم
همم ده ارسلوا دعوه من الدكتور السابق انه
يلقي المحاضره عندهم وراح والقانون محاضره
وكم مبسوط انه في دوله خاصه
تشجع الحكومه هذه والحكومه عندها سجل سيء
الحقوق الانسان الاخر
ماني مستشار في الدوله الى الان الصوره
الذهنيه انه
تشيلي في السبعينات جابهم اللي اعطاهم
السياسات
صحيح يعني ناس من تشيلي نفسهم سووا سياسات
وبحكم انه ما كان في خلينا نقول اييه درس
السابق سووا سياسات السوق حر بشكل
باعوا كل الاصول
شلوا التشريعات في عشرات الالاف من
التشريعات تمام ماهو بانه تم تحسينها او
يعني تغيير الاجراء لا اجراء هذا تم
التخلص منه
التجاره الدوليه وقتها في السبعينات ما
كان في همم نظره الحاليه للعولمه همم
فافتحوا الحدود مع الصرف في قيود على على
الاستيراد والتصدير
واول كم سنه كانت صعبه لانه في عدد من من
الشركات بدل يفلس منتجات تيجي من برا
جدتها افضل همم تشيل الدوله ما كانت
متقدمه صناعيه اما كان في صناعه بشكل كبير
فكان فلسون وكانوا الناس في غضب يعني همم
الاسعار ارتفعت خاصه الخدمات العامه اللي
كانت مدعومه من الحكومه زي الكهرباء زي
المويه
بدك ترتفع الاسعار
كم سنه في السبعينات وبعدين
بدا يتغير شيء معين انه المستثمرين
الاجانب بدهم
وقتها ما كان بشكل كبير فكرنا الحين عن
استقطاب استثمار الاجنبي ونجيب خبرات كان
في نظره سلبيه اكثر
الاستثمار اجنبي جاء مو بانه في تشجيع
موهبه
راحت قالت تعالوا
عدم وجود التشريع اصلا ااا يخلي الموضوع
فيه سهوله دخول بشكل كبير فانا بدخل تنقيب
بدل ما امر على سبع وزارات وامر على سنتين
من العمليه لا همم ادخل بتطلع سجل وتشتغل
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوشن سباي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
القيود
المنخفضه على السوق
مره
بدا قطاع
المعادن بشكل كبير القطاعات الثانيه زي
الصناعيه
فلست بس اصولها موجوده فالمصانه اللي كانت
شيماء يعني منافسه على مستوى اقتصاد
العالمي همم صالح الحين الادوات موجوده
العمال الموجودين واحد فكر جديد يجي ياخذ
المصنع مختلف
في قضيه ثانيه على التجاره الدوليه انهم
بدري جدا
همم السياسه المفتوحه مع مع كل الدول
العالم خلي من السهل ان الدول الثانيه
تفتح لهم التجاره الدوليه
ما كان في السهوله لانه الشخصي او عفوا
الدوله تغير من سياسه معينه ويتم نشرها
على الجميع لا فكان في كل دوله تسوي
اتفاقيه مع كل دوله على حدا كان عمليه
صعبه جدا
بس وجود حدود مفتوحه خليها تكون اسواق دول
اوروبيه دول في امريكا
فالزراعه في الشيلي بتنتعش بشكل كبير
طبعا للمفارقه جيرانهم ارجنتين ارجنتين
اضعاف المساحه اضعاف السكر
عندهم زراعه من اقدم مستقلين يعني سياسيا
من قبل
[موسيقى]
بس سياسه الارجنتين ضد السوق دائما في
تدخل في في الاسعار دائما يتم فيه مثلا
يفتحون فتره المستثمر الاجانب وبعدين
مصادره الاملاك ويخرجون برا السوق وتصير
مصيبه يصير مشكله
فترجعوني يفتحون الدوره
اللي صار في الشيلي الناس يعني
تقول انه في سلبيات وقتها او نعم فتره اول
خمس سنوات او الى ذات الثمانينات لكن
بعدها بدات تختفي من الاخبار
وما احب حط نظريه مؤامره بس واضح ان في
توجه معين في الاعلام كل مكان يميلون
دائما انه اكثر يكونون اقرب لهمم الفلسفه
الاشتراكيه في ذات الاقتصاد فلما يصير في
مثلا مشاكل معينه همم في اي مواصلات للسوق
الحر تطلع للاعلام همم بينما يتم تخفيف اي
اي شيء يدعو لي اشتراكيه الشيء اللي كان
في تغطيه غير طبيعيه عليها فتره السبعينات
ذات التحويل الوضع تغيرت اختفت ما تشوفها
يعني حتى انا رجعت من فتره قريبا اني ابغى
اطلع بعض المصادر
حصلت يمكن فيه
قصير 15 دقيقه او شيء في الجزيره
بالانجليزي قبل ثلاث سنوات او شيء ليش
لانه
طلع فيه
مظاهرات من الطلاب فرجعوا الموضوع هل فعلا
السياسه اللي اللي نفعت الشيء اللي في 30
سنه الحين بدات خلاص ما عاد صار لها طبعا
يوم رجعت الامور جدد تاخر سنتين ما رجعت
طيب ايش صار بالارقام
سكانها حول اقل من 20 مليون
هم
الاعلى في الناتج المحلي للفرد في امريكا
الجنوبيه والكاريبي
باستثناء الهجره الصغيره اللي سكانها
500,000
هم يعني من من اعلى الدول في في
تقييم المنافسه الدوليه في اتجاه الحريه
الحره في الحريه الحريه الاقتصاديه همم
مستوى التعليم اااه غير كده يعني تتوقع
بوجود تشريعات اقل ان بيصير والله في
مشاكل البيئيه هو الشركات الخاصه راح تدمر
البيئه ولا يهمهم المستفيد او ان يكون
مثلا في استغلال همم لضعف الحكومه همم
الدوله رقم واحد في العالم في اعاده تدوير
المياه
وله بشيء يعني تاريخي من زمان هم متميزين
عن 98
كان ااا شلت يعني يتم تكرير او اعاده
تدوير 15% من المويه اللي في موجود عندهم
بس في ازمه مياه
والحكومه تبغى تحل المشكله الاستراتيجيه
يعني
ف
راحوا وازاله مزيد من يعني
للاستثمار في قطاع تكرير المياه ووو فتح
وحوافذ معينه يعني همم
للمستثمرين وجاءت شركات همم من بره همم
الشركات المستثمرين من 98 يعني بدا همم او
استيعاب المشكله في 98 بداوا من 2001 في
بناء ال- همم
المعامل بناء الشبكه الجديده خلال ست
سنوات بس وصاله الى 99% نسبه المياه طيب
على مستوى مثلا طاقه همم الطاقه النظيفه
من اوائل الدول اللي حققت مثل حول 20% من
طاقتها من همم الطاقه الشمسيه
ببساطه بسبب تشريعات
ناتي الموضوع اخر الحين تشيلي
مثلا حققت
تميز في الطاقه الشمسيه الى درجه انه
الاسعار صارت بالسالب لانه لازم يبيعون
الكهرباء ما يتخزن في وقت وقت النهار كلهم
يبيعون كهرب يقل السعر الين ما يصل الى
الصفر ثم بعدين نعطيك رصيد على شان
الكهرباء اللي عندنا ما في شركات فلسفه
طيب لو كان الاستثمار في الطاقه الشمسيه
من الدوله افلاس الشركات هذه هو افلاس
الدوله
الاصول يرجع المسؤوليته همم لو نجيء نشوف
كم ال
الدين الاجنبي الحكومه الشريره الاقل في
امريكا الجنوبيه من الاقل في العالم 7:30
7:30 في المحلي عشان بس نعطي فكره نشوف
مثل الارجنتين جنبهم حول 80% نشوف فيديو
كثير عربيه بالسبعين 80% اا ديون الاجنبيه
والديون الاجنبيه دائما هي خطر انا بعمله
غير عمتك فاذا ما اذا ما سدت ما عندكم
الاجنبيه الدوله في الاسلام
حتى على مستوى البيئه حتى على مستوى
الاستدامه ما هو بشرط انه في سياسه
سياسه للسوق الحر يعني
راح تسبب مشاكل بيئيه لا يلغي انه في
تشريعات عامه اكيد وهذا نرجع نقول انه هو
الدور الاساسي ووو والعكس لما يكون الدوله
مباشر يعطيها قوه اكثر في التشريع
لان في تركيز في البدايه والنقطه ثانيه
في دوله عربيه
الحكومه تملك شركه انتاج التبخر
وتتربح منها في نفس الوقت وزاره الصحه
عندها اهل هدف لانها تخفض يعني تخفض عدد
المدخنين طيب
يزيد
والحين هي من اعلى الدول العربيه في
التدخين لان الحكومه لها لها فائده في
تضارب تعارض مصالح مستحيل ان انه ما يصير
فيه هديه في الموضوع همم
لما يكون في تركيز اللي صار في تشيلي
الحكومه تركز على همم الاثر متعدي او
دائما في دور مهما كان في يعني فوائد
السوق الحر دائما لازم يكون في دروع
تنظيمي لتنظيم الاثر المتعدي والتكلفه همم
التكلفه همم اللي ما يتحملها صانع التكلفه
هذا
كمثال التلوث قد يكون الاربح للمستثمر اذا
عنده مثلا مخلفات سامه يتخلص منها
ليش تسوي لها عمليه مكلفه جدا لكن
المخلفات هذه بتلوث البيئه تمرض ناس
بتكلفهم علاج بتكلفهم او انه تخرب مثل
الاراضي الزراعيه ففي تكلفه هم هم جالس
يتحملها
الحكومه الكبيره بس الحين يعني المثال
رائع ترى
بس ليش ما في ولا دوله
في في كل دول العالم تقريبا همم حتى الدول
اللي تحط بين قوسين احنا
الصين طول عمرها شيوعيه او عفهم من
استقرارها في الصين الحديثه لانه كان قبل
امبراطوريه
فالحكومه تغيرت الحزب الحاكم والحزب
الشيوعي هو نفسه موجود
من 40 الى 100 مليون هذا الكلام في
الخمسينات يعني قريب
استمر الوضع الا لما صار يعني بعد ما ما
هو همم صار فيه الحركه اكثر انه مش نقدر
نسوي همم ناس تتكلم عن نهضه الصين
ويشوفونها في الوقت الحالي بس وقت عصير
كانت خوفه لانه احنا هويتنا شيوعيه اصلا
مدينه واحده وخلاها منطقه اقتصاديه حره
حتى المدينه هذه اخذوه كذا ابعد شيء وفي
اقرب نقطه هون كونج كانت مستقله يعني
فقط في المدينه هذه رح نفتح استثمار اجنبي
راح نشيل القيود عن السوق والتسعير راح
ندخل نعطيهم استقلاليه تامه في اداره
امورهم وبعدين نبغى نشوف كيف العمليات
هامت وهذيك المنطقه هي اللي بدات الشركات
الاجنبيه تيجي
وبدا اللي بكون الصينيين انت
كانت قريه من 10000 او سكانها طبعا
بالنسبه للصين ولا شيء الرقم انت قريه
عايشه على على الصيد صيد السمك
الان هي مدينه بحدود 25 مليون ساكن اللي
هي عاصمه التقنيه في
الصين
المثال يعني نجح اول كم سنه بدات الصين
تطبقوا في شنغهاي هذه منطقه اقتصاديه حره
الاخر
فبدات نفس السياسات تمشي الى مسار خلاص في
السياسه عامه همم
ما هو بانهم ما احد ما في احد اصلا بيخلق
يعني انه اقتصادي كبير بدون ما يكون عنده
همم
اي سوق عنده اي دوله عندها
راس ماليه فنشوف مثلا بريطانيا
اكيد لا يلغي همم وضعنا ان عندهم سوق حر
او ان دوله الراسماليه لكن في ممارسات
اشتراكيه
ونعتقد انه انه او او يتم دائما سرده
بسياق انه تدرب صار كده بدنا صار كده
فالشخص يفهم انه هذا صار غلط صار صح بعده
ما هو بشرط ف مثلا كان الخدمات العامه في
بريطانيا نسبه كبيره خاصه كلها خاصه بما
فيها حتى الاطفال كان خاص
الحكومه في العشرينات في الثلاثينات بدات
انها تقدم الخدمات ثم بعد ذلك تدخل في حتى
قضيه الخدمات المرجحه فكان في همم في
بريطانيا التلفزيون همم التليفون الكهرباء
المويه الخطوط الطيران ال- همم
القطارات كلها ملوك الحكومه فهي ما كانت
كذا
في الثلاثينات العشرينات بدات تصير حكوميه
واستمرت الين ما صار في اشكاليه في
السبينات الواحد كان ينتظر حوالي ثلاث
اربع سنوات عشان يسرق التليفون عشان تشتري
تلفزيون من السوق وتحطه عندي بطلع رخصه
وفي عليها انتظار
انك تاخذ الرخصه هذه وعليها تكلفه
التلفزيون همم كان همم
الطيرانوس
الطيران ويخسر بالملايين
الازمه خلقت انه في يعني خلاص اقتناع معين
انه ما عندي رصيد من موضوع الحالي وهذا
الشيء اللي اللي خلق البي انا تاتشر تيجي
وتبدا مده الخصاصه مره ثانيه طبعا يوم صار
فيهم اقتصادي في التمرينات والتسعيناتهم
طلع مره مبسوطين
الناس
مبسوطه اول ما تبدا يعني الامور تستقر
يبدا وانا يقولون طيب والله هذا الشيء صار
غالي ليش من حكومه ترجع فيه ونرجع في نفس
الدوره يعني بدل ما نشوف انه تطور تدرج هي
الدورات همم والناس دائما همم
يعني ما تفهم الاثر علامات الطويل لانه مع
اي سياسه مهما كانت سياسه خاطئه سياسه
سيئه
المدى القصير في ناس مستفيده فصح يمكن
الناس اللي كانوا
يعني يستخدمونه خطوط طيران ااه تذاكر اقل
من 10% من التكلفتها مستفيدين بس هل هذه
الفائده على الدوله
فالناس ما تفهم المدى الطويل يفهم يعني هو
اللي همه الاستخدام الشخص يحق له يعني حتى
لو همم
حديث على موضوع التعليم او التعليم الجامع
العام همم فهو ضده
ويقول انه ما يكون في الجامعات يعني مملوك
الحكومه لو نبغى ندعم التعليم نعطيهم
فاوتشر او كوبونات وهو يختار الجامعه يعني
ما يصير مدرس الجامعه موظفين للدوله
فقال انا استفدت يعني من معلومكم هو كان
في المحاضره في الجامعه كان معلومكم يعني
انا استفدت من هذا الشيء انا بعد ثواني
درست ماجستير والدكتوراه في نيوجيرسي
وبنام تخرجت ما طبيت ههه
[موسيقى]
التحول مع كان ااا
بس خلونا نغير وغيره يعني كان في دماغريق
يعني
تحول بسيط وصار وخمس سنين احنا حياتنا
حلوه لا اكيد لانه
لازم يكون في بيئه سياسيه همم
سالتني قبل شوي انه كيف مثلا في الدول
عندك
مثلا زي امريكا اتوقع لو تقول اي اي شخص
وش اكثر
مدن في ولايات امريكا اذا اليوم نزل عندها
مثلا التحكم اسعار للايجار
من اكثر ممارسات الاشتراكيه موجود
[موسيقى]
هم الاغلبيه بيكونوا طيب
اللي يصير انه بدون ما يكون في همم يعني
همم
تشريعيه تسمح هذا الشيء صعب انه يصير صعب
انه يصير بجمع الناس همم يمكن بدا في دول
امريكا لانه امريكا يعني بدا الاقتصاد قبل
الدوله
اتكلمنا اصلا كانت مستعمرات متفرقه وكانت
اللي راح هناك تجار يعني وفتره طويله يمكن
عقود قبل لا يكون اصلا في محاوله سيلفي
دوله مركزيه لذلك الى الحين الناس ما هي
مستوعب شويه كيف كل الولايه عندها تشريعات
مختلفه لانها بدات في هذا الشكل لكن
الصعوبه تصير وين في الدول اللي الحكومه
موجوده ولا في اقتصاد فالان السياسات
الحكومه الاقتصاديه اللي اللي بيوجهها هو
على حسب كيف يعني ميول الناس دائما بتصير
على الاكثر يعني شعبويه اشتراكيه القصير
اللي صار اكيد يعني حتى ليش ما كان يطلع
يقول انا مالي دخل في همم في الدوله لانه
كان همم الجيش يعني همم كانت اداره
الدمويه خاصه في البدايه لان في معارضه
كان من النقابات العماليه الى اخره
بس هل
الوضع ده صاير بسبب السياسات لانه 50 سنه
قبل
قبل وجود الجيش كان في مشاكل سياسيه في
الجيلي من عام 25 الى 32 سبع سنوات عشر
حكومات
عشره
وبعدها 50 سنه من تركيا ما حل الموضوع
فكانت بتصير في كذا الحالات همم بس يمكن
وكان في تدخل خارجي الى اي مدى يعني زي
وجود دخول الجيش هذاك الوقت فتره
الانقلابات العسكريه في امريكا الجنوبيه
وكانت سياسيه تحارب بوجود الشيوعيه هناك
فاكيد من صالحهم انه يكون واحده من الدول
هذه حكمها شيعيه همم
لكن اذا اذا نقيس طب ايش صار بعدها هل هل
الدول اللي اللي وصل لانه الجيش راح في
التسعين مع همم مع تغيير الحكومه ويعني
ماعد صارت في نفس الوضع الحين من افضل
الدول في امريكا الجنوبيه لكن الدول اللي
صار فيها انقلاب جات حكومه شيعيه وحتى لو
راح الجيش اللي بافكار الشيوعيه وصارت في
حكومه مدنيه ايش صار بعدها لا تسال
الافكار همم الشيوعيه ماسكه همم
تعاني منها البرازيل الى الحين همم ولهم
يعني قادرين يعني يخرجوا من هالناسق
حل لانه في جاهل لا في دائما في ناس لانها
امور يعني موجوده ومعروفه ففي ناس عارفين
وش السياسات الافضل
السياسه الافضل في كل حاله تحديدا بس
التوجه الى الافضل بس ما يوصلون او او ما
يسمع لهم
اا
متى كنت يعني انت كنت تدخل الحكومه يعني
انه يكون هذا التاخر غير منطقي اللي هو
مثلا همم
تسعير الدواء
كيف تبغاني اخليه والله السوق وهو يحكم
فتخيل يعني وتصير في امثله كثيره ليكون
انه اكتشف دواء اخذ عليهم انه حقوق الدواء
بعدها ب 700 ريال او 700 دولار
الدولار
وينقذ الناس السرطان ولا غيره بس تيجي
تقول لا والله المشكله
طيب هو في دوره الحكومه بس الدور مش تحكم
الاسعار
اذا كان في دواء معين له تكلفه عاليه عن
الناس
تعطيها مباشره الدعم وهم يسرقون الدواء
لما تحدد السعر شو يصير اذا كان الدواء
يعني مطور من نفس الدوله
افضل كفاءات اللي فيها راح يطلعون لانه
اكيد في سوق اخر ما بكم في التحكم ده
بيعطيهم عرض افضل
فصح انك تتحكم سعر الدواء هذا بس الدواء
اللي بعده واللي بعده الدول اشي من برا ما
احد بيعطيك اياه الا بسعره اللي هو يعني
منسي بالنسبه له في الاخير لما تقول تحكم
بالسعر ان الحكومه تدفع بشكل مباشر الفرق
همم الفرق يصير في حافز عند الشركات انه
ما يهمه هو السكر
الناس تقول انه يسعر على كيفه فعلا هو
يقدر يحط السعر اللي هو يبغاه بس ما يعني
هذا الشيء انه هذا السعر يعني ولا ما احد
يجبر يعني اي احد في سوقنا محلي في غير
غير المنتجات المدعومه انه يسعر باي سعره
وشوفه مناسب بس هل بيحقق للمبيعات اللي
يشوفها منسيه او لا ما في احد يشتريه
سوق الادويه كمثال مثلا الادويه في امريكا
واغلى بنفس الاسم التجاري في الدول
في امريكا همم اكتشفت انه ارخص لها يحجزون
تذكره للمريض الى المكسيك ويشتري ياخذ
الدواء حقهم هناك ويرجع ارخص من يشتري
الدواء حقه بامريكا همم طب ايش اللي يعني
خلي الوضع همم هل هو السوق المفتوح
انه في الاف تي اي حاطه قيود على دخول
الادويه من برا ما تدخل حتى قيود شديده
جدا على موضوع اللي هيئه الغذاء
في امريكا همم قيود على تطوير الادويه على
همم احنا نقول تجارب السريريه ولا اخره
وهذا الكلام مو الان يعني همم
عودا الخدامه لكن هو من اكثر منتقدين مثلا
للجهات التنظيميه اللي يفتح لها الباب
انها تنظم بدون قيود
فمن وقتها كان في مشاكل الادويه ما تدخل
امريكا اللي تتطور داخل امريكا مكلفه جدا
وبحكم ان ان اي دواء لازم يدخل يعني يمر
بنفس التجربه
ما تدخل فسووا محاضره في ما يكلنك يعني
كلهم دكاتره كلها وكان هو يقول انه نبغى
نرفع القيود عن تطويل الادويه فتتخيل انه
الدكاتره كلهم معارضين وهذا اللي كان
موجود اليوم المستشفى المستشفى
اسالك قالت ايش تخصص قال لنا في القلب هو
القلب قال ما في ادويه الان موجوده في
السوق في كندا او في بريطانيا
للقلب راح يعني تفيد الناس وتنقذ حالات كم
الرقم موجود
الاف ممكن يكون
فقال يعني انت بتحافظ على الاجراءات
المعقده عشان ما يكون في حالات معينه انها
تتاثر
جانبيه او شيء همم وعادي يتحملون الباقيات
تكلفه همم
الحالات هذه تشوفها اقل من الحالات نسمح
لادويه تيجي من برا بتشريعات اقل ف القضيه
انه مهما كان في يعني تحديد
او قيود على السوق معين الاطراف السلبيه
راح تصير بس قياسها بيصير صعب بدون ما
يشوف انه ايش الايجابيات اللي رح تجي من
السوق المفتوح
تشريعات تؤثر عليك يعني ممكن بكره تجيء
الحكم وتقول
سيارات البتروليه ممنوعه هذه بتفلس كل
الشركات بتطلع الشركات اللي لها علاقه كل
تشريع مؤثر في القطاع الخاص على طول
وفي تاثير اللي هو بالنهايه تسوي شركه
تملك الحكومه فاهيتا الصبح جزء من القطاع
الخاص في ايهما اصلا اكثر ضرر على اكثر
ضرر طبعا انها تدخل وتمارس ادوار القطاع
الخاص في السوق
حر او لا هل الدوله تدخل في عمليه الانتاج
والتسعير او لا اذا كان ما تنتج ولا تحدث
الاسعار وتحدد من اللي ينتج ومين اللي
يبيع معنا عندها سوق حر التشريعات ممكن
تميل اكثر انها تصير اشتراكيه بس ما يغير
من طبيعه السكر
الثنتين
اللي يشوفون الاقتصاد يعمل بقيه اقل بشكل
افضل اكيد انه عرض التشريعات واعرض همم
التدخل المباشر تدخل مباشر كل ما كل ما
تقدم الدوله مع انه موجود ترى يعني موجود
مثلا شركه حكوميه مهما كان مثال واضح همم
يعني هتولد في امريكا لكن همم في
التشريعات همم يمكن هو اللي يكثر حديث عنه
لانه المثال الثاني او تدخل الدوله حكوميه
همم
تواجدوا اقل في الدول الغربيه
فخلاص يعني من يوم صار في موجه خاصه في
الثمانينات قل وجود الحديث عن الشركات
الحكوميه في همم في القطاع الخاص في السوق
همم وصارت تركيز اكثر عن التشريات
التشريعات اكيد انها قاتله يعني همم اشوف
مثلا لما مثل تشيلي ما هو مثال وحيد في
دول يعني همم الدول الاسيويه همم كوريا
سنغافوره كل الدول هذه
وتشوف كيف عمليه التغير اللي صار عندهم
همم
غالبا الناس تعتقد تشريعات انه نشيل تشريع
سيء ونحط تشريع جيد بس هذا يمكن 10% يصير
يمكن 90% انك بس تشيل التشريع بيحدث ذات
وازالته هو التقدم كبير همم سوق منظم
بزياده لا يعني
الشركات الناشئه لو تسالهم هل تفضل اسير
مثلا في مرجعيه لك في سوقك وتنظيم واضح
ولوائح واضحه ولا تدخل في سوق ما احد يدري
ايش المنتج حقك تقول اعطني السوق الاخر
لانه دائما الشركه الناشئه بيكون متجهه
ثوري يكون منتجها ماجر ما جربوها مثل حتى
هم يبحثن وشهم وبانجربون لما يكون في
تنظيم معناه تنظيم خاص على شيء اردني
موجود وفي قيود عليه فعندي مجال اقل
المنافسه همم لمن تكلم على المنافسه الناس
تتوقع المنافسه انها حاله حاله استقراريه
احنا الان عندنا سوق في تنافس لا هو عمليه
اكثر ما هو بحاله
واذا اخذناها بجانب شويه فلسفه
المنافسه هو عمليه قتل المنافسه
انت الان اذا تبغى تنافس شو تسوي
مونتاج مختلف فانا احترمه اليه اسوي علامه
تجاريه مختلفه ناس عندها ولاء وسجلها ولا
احد يقدر يقلدني فانا افتكر قدره 90
بطريقه حالي او اروح الى سوق غير مخدوم
ليه اكون انا الوحيد اقدر اتحكم وانا من
الاوائل
فهذه عمليه منافس لما تيجي الشركه
الاخرى وتشوف في فرصه تروح تحاول انه يعني
تشيل ميزه التنفسيه من المنتجه الي موجود
بميزه التنافسيه عندها هذه العمليه هي
اللي تخلق المعروض تحسن في المنتج همم
يعني نزول في الاسعار لكن همم اذا جينا في
النظريه الاقتصاديه للمنافسه التامه فهي
حاله عدم المنافسه ان يكون كل المنتجات
متطابقه كل الاسعار ثابته كل المعلومات
متوفره عند عند الشخص من شركه الف وشركه
بها اهم صفر لانه الجميع بينزل لها صفر
هذه الحاله خلاص
فاكيد انه التشريعات الى حد معين ضروريه
ولا في يعني خط واضح انه اذا هنا وقف
او انه في حل واحد لكل الدول لانه في
تحديات مختلفه في او حتى نفس الدوله تمر
بمراحل مختلفه اللي اليوم يمكن يكون مقبول
يمكن بعد 10 20 سنه ما عندهم مقبول
بس اكيد همم لازم كل فتره يتم مراجعه هذه
ويكون السؤال وهو كيف نحسنها
ترامب 2016 مع الحمل حقته همم في مشكله
مثلا موجوده في الدول اللي بدات في
تنظيمات التشريات والهيئات صارت عندها 200
سنه مثلا
نظام جديد همم لا يعني عشان يمسح القديم
تخيل تراكم التشريعات على مدنيه سنه مش
ممكن يخلقه في عشرات الالاف من تشريعات
يعني
انذا بوكس على قناه الكتب ما حد يدري عنها
اصلا موجوده المشكله انها تفتح فقرات
قانونيه او او تخلق طلبيه تخوف معين همم
ترامب في 2016
من بيت الابيض فما هو بتشريع من الكونجرس
فكان فقط في فتره انه ما في اي ورقه
تشريعيه همم تطرح في الكونغرس الا بعد
ازاله تشريعين من همم
بنت الشافعي موجوده طبعا اغلبها في
تشريعات من 1800 شيكل اصلا ما حد يستخدمها
يعني بس وجود ازاله التشريعات هذه اكيد
تسبب يعني او تخلق لك رشاقه اكثر في السوق
شفافيه اكثر همم فرصه اقل نسير في استغلال
او احتكار او اي ممارسه ممارسه هذه
لما يصير التشريعات يعني فايق يعني مره
قريت ما ادري والله هي هيئه الناقله والا
وزاره النقل
بس انه شلون يلبس
السائق
ان تلبس ثوب ابيض
من السعوديه بس الثوب
وغير في السعودي
بس ما يحدث هذا الشيء
يعني في شيء فقط تراجع عنه لان النظام
السياحه هو طلع ما قراته بس اول ما طلع
المسوده او شيء كان في اشتراط على الفايف
ستار الخمسه نجوم انه يحط ورده او يستقبل
عميل ابو ورده
بس نرجع نسال هل التنظيم همم راح يخلق
تجربه افضل او منتج افضل او لا همم
الواقع انه يخلق العكس شيء اسواق
الناس الحين مثلا
متضايقه شوي من قضيه التضخم اللي صاير
والتضخم عالمي يمكن في السعوديه
عندنا ظروف تخلي بعض الاشياء ترتفع
ارتفاعات غير مسبوقه
بس يطالبون انه مثلا وزاره الداخليه انه
ليش مصوره تقول انا ما دخل في الاسعار
يعني غير المنتجات المدعومه من الحكومه
القمح او ال- اا الرز او همم
دخل التسريع لكن الناس عندها صوره انه لا
دوره التجاره
في جانب معينه يلمون الوزاره انها مثلا ما
ما تسوي اجراءات كافيه انها تصحح من
الاثار السلبيه هذه باعطي مثال همم العروض
الوهميه في تخفيضات
متمر من جنب محل العطور 50% طول السنه همم
وانا اضحك على الرسائل تجيني على المواسم
يعني انه هذا مواسم عوده المدارس موسم
العيد طبعا اوكي نفهم بس مثلا مفروشات يحط
موسم الكاس العالم همم
وبعدها باسبوعين موسم نهايه العام همم
فيعني في عدم مصداقيه في التخفيضات اللي
موجوده اتوقع وزاره التجاره في السعوديه
يروحيده في العالم اللي تحط رخصه على
التخفيضات انت ما تقدر تخفض اي منتج
الموافقه تجاره عليه بالضبط تحط كم
التخفيض على كل منتج علق اللوحه الباب هذا
غير موجود في اي مكان يعني انا بالطلاعي
بس متاكد انه اقل شيء في اسواق الاوروبيه
وفي امريكا موجود همم
والناس في نفس الوقت اللي يشوفون انه ما
في مصداقيه في العروض اللي موجوده محليا
يشوفون والله عروض الجمعه السوداء في
امريكا وامازون برايم وزي كذا
طيب ما في تشريع هناك ما في رخصه
مو بس كذا يعني حتى وزاره التجاره عندهم
نظام
لضمان حق استرجاع واستبدال العميد
بس بسالك انت درست في امريكا كيف تجربتك
في الاسترجاع والاستبدال في امريكا
همم ولا ولايه في امريكا تجبر اي محل مهما
كان فظاعته انه يسترد او يستبدل
بعض الولايات فقط يقول لك انه اذا عندك
سياسه علقها مش السياسه مالك دخل بس تقدر
تحط اصلا نوريفانت ما في استبدال وراء
اللوحه خلاص بعض الولايات لكن كل الولايات
ما ما في اي احد يعني يجبرهم استبدال
استرجاع اي احد درس في امريكا او حتى طلب
من شركه بامريكا وهو هنا في السعوديه يقول
لك عن تجربتها ممتازه يقول لك انه والله
اعطاني 60 يوم 90 يوم استبدال مجاني طيب
وايش الشيء اللي جبارهم يسوون الخدمه هذه
اذا دائما تشريع مش موجود لانه عامل السوق
اللي سبب هذا الشيء همم
الان والمرت يعطي استبدال الى 90 يوم
يوم كان في الثمانينات او التسعينات كان
هم الوحيدين اللي عندهم 60 يوم استبدال
استرجاع كان غالب حتى المتميزين يعطيهم 30
يوم بس فكان هم عنصر المنافسه عندهم انه
نعطي الدبل المنافسين وفعلا سيدرا السوق
اللي خلاهم يرفعون الى 90 يوم وهو كاسكو
مجبورين هم يعني اذا ما كان في عمليه
السوق هذه
تشريعات ما راح يصير الناس تسال ليش فيه
تخفيضات وهميه مع انه في تشريعات هذه
موجوده لانه دائما مهما سوت تشريعات ما
راح تصير همم يعني همم
ما يعني قبل ما يجي التشريع هذا
كل اللوح الموجوده البضاعه لا ترد ولا
تستبدل
بس هل التشريع هو الحل ولا نحن نشوف ايش
المشكله اللي خلقت الوضع ده لانه ما في
مشكله تصير بهالشكل الا بسبب انه السوق
عندك مقيد في قيود عليه اللاعبين
الموجودين في السوق
انا مثلا اشوف الاتصالات السابقه الناس
كانت يعني جدا مستاء او خدمات الاتصالات
خدمات انا الحين تفاجئ احسها يعني
هسه كويسه
يعني مره صارت في مشكله في الراوتر
وكلمناهم حسين في الليل وجاء خلال ساعه او
اقل يعني تطلب مجهز ما يوصل بسرعه
الفني في ساعه بالليل
اللي اللي خلق التحول هذا هو من السوق صار
في منافسه عاليه مهما كان في قبل قبل بتحط
لوائح لحقوق العملاء او الى اخره ما راح
يعني تخلق ال ال المنافسه اللي موجوده او
تكون يعني حريصه على العميل
وبالمناسبه انا برضه واحده من الامثله
اللي الناس تتوقع انه والله لانه الشركات
في امريكا هي مثلا مقرها امريكا او في
حريصها على عملاء احمد مثلا وانه الشركات
اللي عندنا يعطونا وكلاء ما يكون عريس على
الامير همم بس قرات حاله او او تحليل
الماركه حق همم مكياج
ماركه همم فرنسيه
عميله في امريكا رافعه شكوى في فرنسا انها
همم متعوده دائما نتعامل مع نفس الماركه
هذه في امريكا ومبسوطه على سياسه خدمه
العملاء عندهم راحت فرنسا وتفاجات انه
سياده الاسترجاع اسواق ويعني كان في تجربه
سيئه للعميل فرفعت شكوى كيف يعني انه هذا
احنا ماشيين حسب النظام معين في فرنسا
احنا خلاص همم شركه فرنسيه بس ادائها في
السوق الامريكي افضل لان السوق الامريكي
اكثر تنافسين سوق الفرنسي
اذا انت ما عندك سوق تنافس
تجربه
العميل اذا كان السوق مفتوح والاصل انه
بيوصل الى الى حد معين او خلينا نقول
سابقا موافق القطاعات له في سحوبها الدخول
احيانا ما يكون في منع يعني ما نقول والله
مثلا احنا مقفرين قطعه معين ما تدخل فيه
مع انه في قطاعات معينه للبنوك مثلا في
بيوت كثيره
لكن قد يكون السوق مو مفتوح لان فيه عائق
دخول عالي او يسمونه
علي قد يكون تشريعي قد يكون مثلا صعوبات
حسب البيئه اللي موجوده همم احنا شفنا من
اخر كم سنه من اكثر المشاريع يمكن اللي
شغالين عليها المناطق الاقتصاديه وقضيه
همم تغيير برده في البيئه العدليه وزاره
العدل والانف المنتشريعات همم ايش السبب
السبب انه مهما سويت كوزاره تجاره او
وزاره استثمار وسحلت الحصول على الترخيص
هذه بس الخطوه الاولى انا باجي عندك في
السوق كيف احصل على تمويل كيف احل
الخلافات والقضايا عندي كيف توقع عقود مع
الموظفين هذه كلها يعني في تشريعيه معينه
بقانونيه معينه قد يكون انت فاتح للسكر
وتقول اي همم
لكن عدم يعني وجود بيئه تشريعيه او بيئه
قانونيه مناسبه او حتى مثلا مشكله تمويل
اي مشاكل اخرى يسبب عالي للدخول ما يشجعون
همم همم نيجي على مثلا موضوع همم الوكاله
الوكاله بسبب انه الشركات ما بتحمل خطا
تدخل عندك بشكل مباشر
فمتى مازلت العوائق او المخاطر يفقد
الوكيل المحلي يعني هو ميستو انه يقول
الشركه الاجنبيه انا بحققوا في المبيعات
في السوق بدون ما يكون عليك اي ترتبات
قانونيه او اي ان تتعامل مع التعقيدات
التشريعيه معينه انا اعرف بلدي واعرف كيف
اتعامل معه
فيتحمل المخاطر بالمقابل انه شركه الحفظ
بالارباح فهو المثال الافضل حتى لو كان
همم يعني يحصل عن نسبه من الربح او تجربه
ممتازه للعملاء بس بمجرد ما تتغير الوضع
ما عاد يصير في اي ميزات خلاص ابشر
او انها تعطي عده وكاله فانا اشبه
يعني قبل كان لازم يكون عندك معقم كان
عندك يعني همم
عارف علاقات الجهات الحكوميه عشان تخلص
امورك اول ما صار في يعني منصات الكترونيه
صار بشكل مباشر من الشركه الى ال- همم الى
المناصه
همم للعنصر
بس
بس يعني لا تسال يعني هنا انك تبغى
تشريعات تبغى تحس انه
لازم يكون سوق
وتكون في تشريعات كثيره التحميل
واضح ان يجب ان الحكومه تتوقف يعني الخط
انا قلت انه واضح
لكن في اتجاه خلينا نقول يخلق منتج افضل
في اتجاه معاكس التشريعات اكثر همم
بالتاكيد انها انها سلبيه همم الى اي درجه
تحافظ على على همم خلينا نقول الاثر
المتعدي على الناس على الاثار البيئيه على
الاثار غير محسوبه همم لازم يدرس لذلك
يصير فيه عمليه التشريح اصلا على الحكومه
فاي جهه حكوميه معينه ونشات لغرض الرقابه
على قطاع معين ما يكون هم اللي يعني
ينفذون ويراقبوه بشكل مباشر هم اللي يعني
يخلقون التشريعات لازم تمر بعمليه اخرى
واحيانا جهات الحكوميه تؤثر على بعض
نشوف مثلا القطاعات معينه
يعني تصل الى مرحله الوزاره والهيئه
المنظمه للقطاع يعني حسنت كل شيء عنه
فيضطرون يجيبون الهيئه الفلانيه والوزاره
الفلانيه نسوي يعني اجتماع عشان نحل
التعرضات اللي موجوده بين التشريات
في جانب اخر عشان كذا بتحمس شويه
لما يكون التشريح واحد على كل النطاق
الاقتصادي صعب احنا نقيس الايجابيه
والسلبيه همم
يعني انا قلت انه الخط مو واضح ولا هو
بنفس التشريع والمثال يعني ينفع لكل دوله
في كل وقت طب كيف نقدر نقيسه نقدر نقيسه
بالتطبيق
فلما يكون مثلا في نظام واحد للرخص
البلديه او الممارسه التجاره معينه او شيء
على مستوى المملكه طيب اذا هو مثلا له اثر
سلبي او شيء مان طب مقارنه بايش يعني
اذا كان الوضع السابق مثلا مره سيئ معناه
انه ما تقدر تقيس الفرصه الفائده لكن اذا
كان مثلا في منطقه اقتصاديه حر ولها
استقلاليه
ووو مثلا تطلع نظام جديد في كيف يسمحون
للاستثمار في الطاقه النظيفه بقيود اقل
واكتشفنا انه والله في نمو هائل عندهم
بسبب تشريح هذا ممتاز نجي نقارنه المنطقه
الفلانيه شوف المنطقه الفنانيه سوا طريقه
هذه
فهذا الشيء يمكن شوي اللي اللي
يفيد مثلا همم الاستقلاليه الموجوده مثلا
في روايه امريكا لانه في تشريعات جدا يعني
مضره وخلينا نقول الاشتراكيه تصير لكن
بحكم انه في اكثر من ولايه همم
الاقتصاد بشكل عام يخفض ضرار عليه
فكلفانيا من اكثر الولايات اللي تصدر
تشريعات وتقيد السوق
انه في شركات تطلع وين تروح تروح تكساس
لهم
همم
طلع راح الى الولايات اخرى
مثلا التحكم بالاجارات مدن نيويورك
مشاكل همم همم مثلا مدن اخرى لا عندها
توجه مختلف
فانا وحده من الاشياء اللي اللي كنت
اقراها على موضوع بارت لاند اللي في اورجن
همم سووا يعني قيود معينه على على اسعار
الاجر
ولا عندهم الايجارات من اهل الايجارات
اللي موجوده همم فسووا القيود وبعدين يطلع
في همم بعد كم سنه في مشكله في السكن
همم طيب ليش الموجود في مثال موجود يعني
المدينه فيها هجره عاليه متوجهه
ولا عندها قيد على الايجار والعكس يعني
الحكومه المحليه مسهل التشريعات بشكل كبير
لما تروح تشوف الارقام تشوف انه مقابل كل
ااه بالنسبه للسكان مقابل كل همم رخصه
بناء في في بورتلاند في خمسه رخص بنا في
اوسطن مقارنه السكان
حتى لو ما كان في حدود
للارتفاع الايجار في اوستن السعر ما يرتفع
بشكل خيالي لانه فيه معروض من الجسم
المبنيه الجديده تخطي الطلب لكن في باطلنت
وقفوا الاجارات همم مع الصرف في حافز احد
يبني اطلع فصر في مشكله حتى يعني الموجوده
في بطن لمده ترتفع بشكل همم
فوجود يعني مناطق اقتصاديه نقدر نقيس شويه
اثر التشريعات هل هو همم
ايجابي او سلبي ونقدر برده
على الدوله بشكل عام اني اسوي تشريع معين
او العمليه صعبه لما يصير في منطقه
اقتصاديه عندها
ابتسامات اقل من سوريا اقل متقاطع اقل مع
جهه الثانيه يقدرون يطبقونا بشكل سريع
يشجع ان يصير في مثال موجود
مع الوقت تستخدم
لولو تعبنا مع اهل الدوله كلها اكيد همم
وحتى تنقلها من همم يعني او او تشجعك تجرب
اشياء جديده يعني في تخوف على مستوى
الدوله انه يكون يعني انا مثلا ما ماني
مشجع ابدا العملات الرقميه همم وفلسفيه
وضدها شويه لكن اشوف مثلا في البحرين وفي
همم في ابو ظبي
وبدات الشركات ممكن العملات الرقميه او
المشفره ما يصير لها او همم والناس تطلعوه
منها لكن وجود الناس اللي يعملوه في
القطاعه في ابو ظبي في البحرين اكيد
هم جاوبوا بجربوشه الجديد قد يكون همم ما
ينفع بقفونه بس بيطلعوا بشيء همم مجرد
وجود البيئه اللي تستقطب النوعيه هذه
الناس هذه اجابه
انا مالي اذا اتكلم
سعوديين اكثر
من يعني شعوب العربيه الثانيه اكثر عاطفيه
انا لحظها بشكل كبير بصراحه
عشان كده في قبول اكثر انه في وجود للسوق
الحر في السعوديه حتى لو كان في ناس تتكلم
انه يشكون الاسعار زي كذا بس بشكل عام
الناس بتقبله اكثر
تنافوذ شركات الحره تفتح الفرص وناس
تستثمر في تقبل اكثر انت شيء وما اتوقع
انه طارق يعني انه شيء بس من اخر سنه يعني
من زمان في الطبع العربي في السيارات همم
ناس تشوف من بره تحكم انه والله العرب
الجزيره همم يعني هم فقط الجماعه
بس لا في عندهم همم روح فردانيه معينه
مع انه حتى على مستوى فلسفي اللي اتهم
الراسماليه بالفردنيه شويه ما يفهم يعني
اشتراكيات
عامل الفرد اااه
بصحن تعطيه خيارات وانه هو عنده مسؤوليات
معينه لكن ترتعامل الفرد كجزء من اسره
انه في مكون
اسره النواه همم
بينما اشتراكيه يكون لا انه انت كثرت همم
حتى كان في همم كلام على على سياسه همم
الضريبه على الميراث يعني في نقاش همم همم
اوكي الضرائب يعني تقلل الحافز انك تشتغل
الطريق كل ما قال للحافز لابد بحد معين
يعني همم دوله تاخذه
للخدمات العامه بس الى الى الى اداره دفعت
بقل الحافظه نفس الاشتراك او تنتج فواحد
متطلاب كان يقول طيب نحط طريقه او الضريبه
الميراث نرفع ال 100% تصير انت اذا همم
يعني عندك اي مبلغ بعد وفاه خلاص روح
للدوله كلها قال كده انا ما اخذت من
الداخل فقال الحافز
فانا الناس من الاقتصاد اللي كان يرد عليه
لكن قال همم انت شكلك ما عندك يعني
انه في بدايه حياتك في حافز تشتغل بنفسك
بس بشكل سريع يصير حافزك حافظ للعمل
اذا اذا مشيت فا الراسماليه تفهم هذا
الشيء ااه وتفهم برضه انه كيف انه في
خيارات معينه تاخذها مهم منطقي لانفسنا
لكن همم منطقيه اذا شفناها في في مجتمع
الاسره او مجتمعنا الدائره الطريقه همم
لا تشيل هم انه في احد يدعمك لان الدوله
تكفل فيك لا تشيل هم او ما تقدر انك مثلا
تخلق مسار معين لعيالك لانهم بي همم بتكفر
الدوله فيهم التعليمهم همم بصحتهم تشغيلهم
همم عشان كده ما رحتم ثروه لانه انت تحدثت
تعيش بس انا بعطيك اللي يعيشك اذا توفيت
خلاص عيالك انا اهتم فيهم فكده بتحسس
الفرده طبعا في فدرك حايك له كلام كثير
الموضوع على الراسماليه والفنيه
وفي لها كتاب جميل برضو مترجم يتكلم على
تحديدا همم
يعني كيف همم الراسماليه نطرتها للفرد
والمسؤليتها همم وكان يقول ان الفدانين من
الجانب الايجابي انه انا اعطيكم مسؤوليه
انك كنت بقراوات تقدر تاخذ قرار شو اللي
يصلح نفسك تشتري همم لكن همم في سياق
الاسرائيلي عندك
الان ما يهمني راس ماليه ولا اشتراكيه ما
يهمني تدخل الحكومه ولا ما تتدخل
الدوله تحمي المواطن
والشركات
والمنظومه امنيه واقتصاديا وهمم يعني
وتعطيهم شكل حياه الرفاء يكونون عايشين
كريمه اذا توفرت
باي شكل فليكن وتجد مثلا في الخليج مثلا
عندنا اذا اخذنا
السعوديه
يعني الكويت فيها اقل اكثر دبي دبي مثال
يعني على بعض هذه الاشياء فكيف انه حكم كل
شيء
والحياه حلوه مستمر
لا لا انا بسوي الشركات انا كحكومه خليني
اسوي اللعبه انا عندي الهم اني اخلي حياه
المواطن كريم
بس اذا اذا احنا اتكلم على شيء مستعد
لن يكون هذا الشيء يعني يقدم الرفاهيه او
يقدم مستوى افضل المواطنين علامات الطويل
انت قلت ما يهمني ايش السياسه او ايش
التوجه مقابل الحياه هذه ترى كلمه الرئيس
الصيني اول رئيس جاء بعد معه
يوم قال انه انت بتحط سياسات راسماليه
واحنا دوله الشيوعيه وكيف تسمح هذا شيء
نصير قال ما يهم وشلون القط والفار
لكن
السوق المحلي اللي عندنا
الان لا نغفر
في ظل وجود همم اقتصاد نفطي يعني في
محاولات لكن حتى مثلا دبي هي جزء من
منظومه خليجيه في يعني فوق كم تريليون من
اراده همم
نسير في مثلا 20 30 مليار تمر على همم على
دبي وفي نسبه ما لها علاقه في النفط لكن
تتوقع انه موجود النقطه هذه مره مهمه همم
ما اقول انه مثلا اخذ ناجح بس لا ننسى انه
في سياق معين هل تقدر تسوي والله نموذج لك
معين همم اقتصادي او حب في في كل مدينه
خليجيه مستحيل كلهم يصيرون مركز همم اللي
اللي ينفع الان في في ظل وفره الاراده
النفط في ظل عدد سكان المستقبل همم احنا
شفنا عمان الين قبل يعني السنه هذه هي
مرتبه اسعار النفط كانت الميزانيه في حادث
كبير مثلا سنوات
يزيد فكانوا ماشيين بنفس النموذج همم كل
الخدمات العامه من الحكومه همم يعني همم
كل شيء همم
الى درجه معينه همم في التحكم حكومي فيه
بس يوم راحت همم اراده النفط ما عاد صار
النموذج هذا مجدي
فلما نيجي نتكلم على على سوقنا المحلي هو
اكيد هو الكلام ما هو انه فقط انه نسمع
انه في سياسات معينه للسوق الحر هي جيده
نطبقها لا لانه في امثله موجوده في تاريخ
موجود
وفي نبره معينه حتى السوق المحل اللي عندك
انا قلت انه كل شيء راح ياخذ كوبي بيست او
انه في دفعه واحده
فلازم نحنا نعرف
وش الوضع الاستثناء اللي احنا فيه يعني
اكيد وجود حجم ضخم في الاقتصاد اااه يتوقف
يعني حتى لو سنوات قليله يعتبر كان متوقفه
ما عندك صناعات بديله ما راح ما في سوق
يعني همم
بسبب انه ب 70 100 سنه النفطيه بتكون يعني
ما تخلي اي شيء غيرها جديد
عندك حل يا اما انك تخلي الوضع زي ما هو
وتستمر السوق
نفسها مستقبلك وهذا هذا قابل ناسيه بس
يكون مؤلم جدا همم
فالناس لما ما اعتذر في لها دخل تضطر انها
تشتغل تخلق وظائف تخلق شركات لما يعني
ترجع على على مستوى معيشه قلبك كثير من
المستوى المتعوده عليه وتبدا من الصفر
لانه هذا الوضع يتطور في الاقتصاد ما في
احد ابدا يعني مستوى عالي همم بس اذا ما
تبغى الهبوط هذا الكبير يصير همم
استغل الفائق اللي عندك من الايراد همم
انك تسوي همم
الفتره معينه العمليه هذه ما راح تصير همم
يعني خلينا نقول ناجح اتوقع ما في احد همم
مستوعب هذا النقطه في محاولات ما راح تنجح
همم في اصلا يعني بيكون في خلاف ولابد
يكون فيه حديث همم انه طب همم تتدخل في
بعض الصناعات في البدايه عشان تبدا طب
وشيء صناعه اللي بتحتاجها هل مثلا كان همم
ممكن صح كان القهوه نصف مرض ضروري انه
يسوي فيه دعم المزارعين في الفتره بس يوم
تحالف مثلا معهم دخل في السينما هل كان في
شيء ايجابي لانه بعد اربع خمس سنوات الحين
متوفره في كل مكان وكل المشتركه خاصه
فممكن ما كان لا داعي ندخل في السينما بس
له القهوه
في عمليه التحول راح راح يكون في همم
التجارب
انه فشل لكن من البدايه المبدا يعني وش
اللي يحدد اللي ندخل فيه وما يدخل فيه ترا
يعني في همم سالفه انها من كثر كيوما اكثر
ضررا ان كثري انه تدخل الحكومه في القطاع
الخاص اكثر ضروره
مدري ايش حصل عكس
لان يعني هنا خليه يدخل زي مثلا
ما عندي مشكله
عادي يعني
شركه من السوق
يعني شغلتين مستقله عن بعض
الناس
قادر
طيب
يجب ان يتوفر فيها عمره لا يقل عن 18 ولا
يزيد خلاص
[ضحك]
كبير حتى الاشكاليه
عندها شركه ملوك لها
بحكم الجميع
بعد فتره في البدايه انشئت انها تقدم
خدمات الوزاره يعني يبون يختصرون الوقت
يبغون يمورونا اكثر في التعاقدات الى اخره
بعد وقت انتهى المرحله هذه تطورنا خلاص في
حد معين يعني انك تحسن من التجربه الين
خلاص ما عاد فيها ففي تكلفه للشركه هذه
خاصه ان انت شايف كم يعني شوف الرواتب
عاليه افضل مكاتب كل شيء يعني على مستوى
عالي طيب بعد فتره بيصير فيه ضغط همم يلا
الشركه
تجيبوا همم يعني دخل خارجي
ادخل نفسه اول
شيء راح يبدا فيه اللي هم منافسه في
العقود الحكوميه من وزاره الاسره
وفي استثناء من الشركات الحكوميه يرسي
عليها
العقد او شركه تبع الوزاره يرسل عليها
العقد بدون ما ينزل العقد
موجود هذا الشيء لذلك قبل يمكن اسبوع او
تحديث جديد طلع فيه استثناء انه اذا
الشركه هذه مدرجه في السوق الاسهم
من
القرار ليش انه علم ادرجت في السوق علم
الان تقدر يعني نظريه كان قبل القرار هذا
انك تقدر تروح للمساره وتاخذ عقد بدون ما
تحكي
شركه في السوق هذا الشيء يعني يعني مو
معرس يمكن للحين ما طلعت مشاكل لما نشوف
انه
هل المبدا صح ولا لا لازم ما نقيس على فقط
الفتره الحاليه نقول اوكي لو استمرينا
بصير طيب ناخذ الاكسترين ناخذ الاقصى مدى
ممكن يروح عليه لو الشركه الحكوميه هذه
قررت تاخذ ايرادات اخرى وعندها يعني حقا
هتنافس او تاخذ عقده بدون منافسه طيب كيف
انا اقدر اتدخل طيب لو الان مثلا شركه هذه
في قطاع معين فكرت بسوي منصه زين وحكم
علاقتها مع الوزاره لا اي همم شركه بتربط
الالي مع الوزاره عن طريق انا وانا اتحكم
في التشري يعني الطريقه هذه همم او ممكن
الوضع للشركه ممتاز اللي اللاعبين في
القطاعات صعبه غير
ما رح يكون في استجابهم بس تشريع عندهم
برضه جزء تنفيذي او ينافس في السوق كله
وضع كويس
ممكن الان نحنا نتكلم في مراجعات دوريه
يعني المنزلات لا كيف عندهم استثناء
همم بس ما نضمن انه لو استمر الوضع حتى
مستقبلا ان ما بتصير نفس التعرضات همم
همم
تضارب المصالح راح يخلق تشريعات التعقيديه
اكثر راح يخلق تفضيل للشركات هذه طيب انا
ودي افهم حاجه همم ليش الشركات المملوك
الحكوميه ناخذها بندرس البيئيه
والخصخصه ننظر لها بشكل ايجابي رغم اني
اشوفها في نهايه المطاف شيء واحد انت تقصد
الخصص من ناحيه كيف
الاتصالات السعوديه بالكامل
بدنا نخصصات اصبحت شركه العالم
يعني
ومع ذلك
باي طريقه
الان
كل مره نجيبها بشكل الاجابه ثم الفرق ايش
معنى عادي
انه اذا اذا جهه او المنظومه مملوك
الحكومه مهما كان شكلها القانوني فهي
حكوميه يعني حطيتها شركه حطيتها
همم موسخه خيريه تمنع مملوك الحكومه
هل الصندوق الاعتبار والصندوق ملوك
للحكومه فبالتالي المملكه الحكومه اللي
يثرب في اس تي سي شغله ان نزل نزلت كلاسهم
30% الان الحكومه باعت همم كميه اضافيه
صارت 50% او 50 همم بالطريقه هذه كل ما
تخاف من كثر الحكومه كل ما يقول لها اقرب
للسوق لا يعني الوضع مثالي بس انه اذا اذا
انت بديت ان عندك جهات معينه همم حكوميه
فالافضل صح وضعها تطرحها في السوق الين ما
تنتقل الى المستثمرين ما راح تقفلها ابدا
جديد هذا الشيء اللي يصير في اي حركات
خاصه موجوده يعني مثال شيلته يعني شركات
الملوك الحكومه باعوا هذا اللي سواه يمكن
نختلف في قضيه التدرج يعني ممكن اقول لا
والله في قطاع معينه ترى ناضج الان اليوم
بيع كلها همم ممكن في ناس ثانيين يشوفوا
نفس الشركه يقول لا يعني لا زال في حاجه
للحكومه تكون لها همم تحكم في مسجد الشركه
الى اخره بس لما اتكلم على الخاص هي
الملكيه الخاصه طب ليش يتكلم عن الملكيه
الخاصه هل لنا في همم شويه همم لخبطه
بينها وبين قضيه ان في كفاءه وفي تحقيق
الارباح لانه الشركه بتحقق ارباح
همم اذا هي شركه ما تعمل في سوق في تنافس
ما تقدر تقيس هل الاربعه هذه حقيقيه او لا
لانه ما في تنافس عليها فممكن ان في ربح
محاسبي ان يتحقق في ارباح اكثر من
التكاليف لكن ممكن في تكاليف مدعومه ممكن
في احتكار لخدمه معينه ممكن في تكلفه
اضافيه فحل عميل النهائي بس انه مجبور ما
عنده خيارات فما تقدر
الشغله الثانيه همم ما هو بشرط انه القطاع
الخاص كل شركه القطاع الخاص اكثر كفاء
الغالب لا في الغالب من 80% 90% همم
كفاءتها منخفضه وخدمتهم سيئه ولذلك انها
98% من الشركات الخاصه
حتى لو 90% من الشركات الحكوميه اداءها
ممتاز وفيها كفاءه عاليه فيها كفاءات
ال 10% مهما يعني
خسرت او كذا ما راح تقفل راح تقدر راح
تسمر موجوده راح تستمر اعطيك عدم كفاءه في
السوق
يعني في الصين في بعض الولايات
كثير من الشركات لا زالت في الصين مملوك
الحكومه وبدات كده واستمر
معين لا سياسه من الدوله لذلك النظام
عندهم الهجين يعني هم حققوا نموه معين من
فتح السوق وبعدين بده يحكموا فيه
مشاكل لكن عودتنا على الشركه في شركات
كثيره حكوميه فتره من الفتره تكبر خاصه في
البدايه ما في تنافس كده مثلا شركه تنجيب
همم همم ما في احد شغال قبلك تبدا
العمليات على طول داخل ارباح مهما كان في
يعني عدم كفاءه مع الوقت لا في منافسه همم
في السوق العالمي في منافسه من داخل
الدوله همم
بدات التراكم عدم همم الكفاءه في العمل
يبدا يثقل على الشركه تبدا الحكومه همم
الاقليميه او همم المدينه اللي مشرف على
شركه هذه تقفل المنطقه بتقول تنجيم في
المنطقه هذه خاص خاص بالشركه لحمايتها
هذا الشيء ما يساعد الشركه يعطيها مجال
اكثر التراخي لان انا ما في مثال اخر همم
ايش يصير بعد فتره خساره تاخذ منك اكثر ما
تاخذ ولها اسم وجود والعدد ما هو بالعشرات
او المئات وبالاف سيبونا زومبي او همم
شركات الزومبي هو اللي ميت ويعيد الحياه
بس
تحركت
وصلت الى مرحله الانها تسبب ثقل عالي على
الحكومه سواء بشكل مباشر لانها تقتل الفرس
البديله شركه اكثر كفاءه او همم
البنت همم
اكثر من الواقع لكن هي اضعاف المعادلات
العالم
طب وين القروض هذه وليش ما هو مثل البنوك
تقفلها او تسيل الشركات لانها اغلبها
رايحه لشركات حكوميه فشركه حكوميه عندها
مصاعب البنك برضه الحكومه فلا اعطوهم
تموين افتحوا لهم خط اضافي
ويبدا الموضوع يستمر بالطريقه هذه
الملكيه او عفوا شركه خاصه شركه عامه هو
الملكيه هل الملكيه عامه ولا خاص هل حجم
الملكيه طيب يفرق اذا انا املك الاغلبيه
ولا اقل اذا كان ما في اي تحكم همم كما
يؤثر لانه مثلا في صناديق
مستثمر في 10 شركه في العالم بعض الشركات
استثمار عن طريق المؤشر فبعض استثمار اهلي
في سوق الاسهم لها وزن معين معياري جزء من
الاستثمار راح يجيك
فانت كمالك شركه او شركه السوق الاسود
ما تدري اصلا
لما يصير عندهم نسبه معينه يقدرون الى
مسجد
بوجودك في عضويه مجلس اداره يخليها حكوميه
يعني اذا قلنا اذا نكون قارن بين نسبه
الملكيه وبين تاثيرها على الشركه يعني
اكيد انه 100% بيكون شركه حكوميه
اقطاع لكن همم 0.1 ما تقدر تقول ان شركه
تحولت قطار عام يعني نسبه بسيطه وين الرقم
بالضبط
معادله رياضيه يعني ممكن يصير في همم
ملكيه بنسبه 20% لكن الشركه خاصه مويه
زيهم زي اي همم ولا اخر همم برده يفرق انه
هل الاستثمار جاي من من الحكومه اللي لها
صلاحيه في القطاع اللي انت فيه همم بمعنى
مثلا همم
مستثمر في شركه في السعوديه بس حكمت
النرويج ما عندها اي همم تاثير على على
السوق المحليه فمهنت تملك او في الاخير
كانها شركه من من شركات السوق مثلا الحين
يعني ايه الحكومه تملك في اوبر
اكثر من 25
[موسيقى]
لها تاثير على التشريعاتها تاثير يعني حتى
لو كان مثلا داخل السعوديه بس السعوديه ما
تشكل يعني عمليات كبيره من عائله اوبر في
العالم
فنفس اللي ذكرتها النروي شركه عندنا برضه
حكم السعوديه في شركه في السوق الامريكي
ما راح يكون في تاثير لكن اذا وصلت الى
نسبه معين انهم يتاثرون همم
ممكن تعامل كشركه حكوميه يعني انا ما ابغى
ادخل في جانب القانوني يمكن في مختصر همم
بس في شركات كثيره
بسمه شركه لها هدف ربحي تدخل الاسواق اللي
بره بس تملكها حكومه ما يتم معاملتها
كاشركه فتمنع مثلا من من دخول بعض
القطاعات او دخول في مناقصات مع الحكومه
احنا شفنا مشاكل صارت مع هواوي في امريكا
[موسيقى]
الحكومه حتى لو كان همم يعني بشكل نظامي
همم سجلات في الصين ما يملك الحكومه ملوك
الموظفين بس ما في احد يعني يصدق ال همم
كانها يعني
الحكومه يعني
يصير يعني انه الشركات الحكوميه هذه
احيانا يعني
ما اقدر اشوفك غلط يعني او ما اقدر اشوف
الفرصه الي اجازه تسويها زي مثلا سابك يوم
سابك ايراداتها اكثر من ايرادات دبي كلها
وهي شركه حكميه 100% بعدين يعني بدات خارج
من هاي الانبياء والكلام اللي ارامك
بس يعني تقدر
تشوفها على الجانب الاخر ممكن الاحمر يعني
كل هذه المشاريع مفيده يعني في تشكيل في
صناعه الدوله لان الحكومه هي من يسمع دوله
جيده والدوله سيئه بغض النظر عن الموارد
حقتها اللي يخلي الدوله
تتعامل مع هذه المسائل واختارت الاشياء
اللي تناسبها عشان تصنع منها الدوله جيده
بدون اي موارد موجوده واذا كان النفط برضه
هنا في العراق
فنزويلا كيف انه بكل هل القذاره من النفط
والاحتياط العالمي لانها دوله الفقيره
فهذه الحركه الحكومه تحسنها دائما تعود
بالفائده
للدوله اجمالا اكيد له دور رئيسي
اساسيات حكوميه حتى لو كان سوق حر في
الاخير نفس الدوله نفس مواردها نفس اللي
تحت الارض نفس البشر لكن كان في سياسات
مختلفه للحكومه كان كان نسبه كبيره من تحت
فقط
في افريقيا تنتج مليون وعندها يمكن من
عرفات الدول الالماس همم
المفارقه انه حوالي 88% من السكان يعتبرون
تحت خط الفقر
بالقوه الشراعيه له خمسه دولار في اليوم
حسب دولتهم مختفيه
لكن في مكان في العاصمه
تحصل يمكن اغلى وجبه كنتاكي في العالم
فكيف دوله فقيره هالمستواه وعندها في
فنادق فاخر
قطع النفطي يعني جالس يدار من شركه حكوميه
لكن جالس يدار بشكل مستقل تماما يعني
الاقتصاد همم
تعاقدات خارجيه والفلوس همم تطلع ولا في
يعني لا هو بالسوق جالس يشتغل ان همم
اكيد انه الدور اساسي للحكومه في
تشريعاتها في تنظيماتها همم نموذج ناجح
ونموذج لكن كيف يتم تنفيذ هذا الشيء او
الادوات اكيد بيكون في اختلاف لما يكون
همم سوق هو اللي يصنع بشكل حر مع
التشريعات حكوميه وتعطيل في المناسبه
تعطيه الحمايه الاستقرار اهم يعني همم
نقطه سواء على مستوى هنا وانا تشريح
همم
تقدر تتاكد بشكل اكثر ابنه النماذج راح
تطلع انها مربحه بشكل فعلي موهوب ارباح
فقط سوريه
يعني
انه في ربحيه الان على الدفاتر لكن ممكن
فقط استفاده انه الخامه مدعوم ولا لان لها
معامله تفضيليه ما احنا حاطين عليها نفس
الرسوم نحطها على شركه التاليه همم او انه
نحميها في اسواق معينه اللي يصير انه قدره
الحمايه هذه جايه من فلوس النفط وقدره
الدعم الفلوس طيب الفكره كلها انك تخلق
اقتصاد متنوع مستقل عن النفط انه لما
ينتهي النفط تقدر تبني دوله مزدهره بدون
ما يكون في دعم طب اذا راح الدعم والشركات
هذه اللي عايشه في فقاعها ممكن بعضها لكن
لما يروح الحمايه هذه راح تنشف ما تبغى
جزء كبير منها ما هو جالس يتحققيه احنا
ذكرنا في مثال الصين انه الشركات خسران
يعني كثير منها
لكن مع الوقت خلاص يعني همم كان همم في
اشياء سهله في البدايه تقدر تسويها مع
الوقت لابد في تنافس لابد في ضغط
الناس تخاف شوي من موضوع انه شركه تقفل
وشركه تفتح لكن السوق اللي ما فيه الحركه
هذه معناه انه اكيد في همم خسائر موجوده
ماهم جالس نحسبها في الاخير همم برده همم
لما اتكلم على الاقتصاد انت تتكلم على
اهداف مواد
فممكن حتى في نموذج بدون دعم بس الموارد
الجلسه استخدمها الشركه هذه همم يمكن لبس
تقديمات في قطاع اخر تصير في ذبحيه اعلى
همم الاشكاليه انه العمليه هذه عمليه
متغيره لحظيه يعني بشكل يعني دوري دائما
يصير حسب ديانه ملكه السوق حسب الطلب
العالمي حسب الطلب المحلي همم انك تحط
قرار توجيه الموارد همم بيملس اداره شركه
واحده او هيئه واحده واحده مستحيل تحصل في
همم اختيار صحيح وكفى علمته الطويل مثل
انه ملايين الناس تحاول انها تستغل الفرس
انها تعطي كفى
حتى لو كان في امثله ناجحه اييه
ذكرت سابك
المفروض انه سابك وصلت الى حجم معين ان
الحكومه تطلع منها
ما تروح تنافس في الدار يعني خاصه ان نحنا
مقنين انه لابد في دعم في الفتره هذه لان
احنا نعالج موضوع اعتمادنا عن النفط
الفتره سابقه لكن كيف افهم انه مثلا سابك
وزعتر ارباح ما حقه وزعت ارباح 15 مليار
قبل سنتين هذا اخر شيء كره وعندهم ماليه
في مليار ونص وصديقه النهائي خلاص
حسن
يمكن
هذا
العمليه يعني صعب انها بتصير في شركه
مرعبه يعني صعب تيجي شركه خاصه سبحان
مليارات تروح تطلب دعم بدون الناس كلها
تمثل دعم انت روح البنوك الخاصه همم
مفروض يوجه للقطاع جديده
فيعني يمكن عدم الكفاءه او يجينا من
الراحه انه الوضع مريح همم في همم في همم
في دعم حكومي في سوق مقفل لما لما يبدا في
توجهه من السوق يعني يفتح يصير في خطر
عليها الله
الله يعافيك شكرا لك شكرا لكم شكرا لتركي
القحطاني و ايمن الحمادي في اعداد هذه
الحلقه وهذا موسى في التصوير جميل عبد
الاحد في التحرير وضياء الدين المدني في
الهندسه الصوتيه وعبد المجيد العطاس في
التلوين هذا فنجان احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع وينشر كل الانتاج بحب من
مدينه الرياض
لا جيد في الوقت الحالي انه في شويه ناس
الموضوع
عندي مشاكل
240 من اليوم اللي قريته يمكن
لانه 500 مليون يورو على كامل الفتره
سنتين ونصف
هذا اللي انا قراته 50 مليون يروح لها
سنتين ونصف ما ادري دقيقه او لا لانه ما
تابع صراحه بس همم بس هو اكيد انها اغلى
صفقه انتقال خاصه الانتقال حر يعني المبلغ
راح مباشره
كثير يعني طبعا
ليش ما يفرقنا انا خسرت وحده
كذا لو
لو
لاعبين
ثلاثه
لان هذا ايش من الراتب وهذاك صفقه الثقه
الاقتصاديه
الحين نقدر نقول
التلفزيوني ولا تذاكر التذاكر يقول كنا
تدخل خمسه مليون
قمصان واللي على السياحه كثير حاولوا
يبردون هذا الرقم
هذا الرقم
اقتصاديا لكن الامثله ذكرتها كلها
استثماريه يعني انا جبت
وبدخل مبيعات تذاكر او مبيعات قمصان هذه
استثمار مباشره
لانه همم ناس يمكن تحاول تفهم والكلام هذا
من زمان
الارقام الكبيره كيف تنتبريرها
واذكر بدات يعني من اول صفقات صفقه ديفيد
بيكم طلع قلت ما اتابع الكوره لكن بس من
الجانب الاستثمار
2002 اليوم راح مدريد كانت اغلى صفقه
وقتها وكانت جزء من سلسله لاحقان بارقام
فكانوا يبدلون جزء من العمليه النترا يوم
راح بكم باعد ريال مدريد عدد قمصان كذا
ودخل قيمته ولا ومن ذاك التاريخ مع كل
صفقه قياسيه نفس الخبر يطلع يعني انا
هاكان قبل لا يجلس نادر لكن
وقتها على موضوع انه كيف الارقام يتم
التلاعب فيها في عشان تطلع بسياق معين في
الاعلام وكان واحده من الامثله همم
الاعلام الرياضي فهمم نفس الخبر تكرر على
رونالدو يوم راح يوفنتوس
طلعوا انه صفقته كان كانت ب 100 وشيماء
مليون وانهم باعوا 60 مليون قمصان في 24
ساعه فادخل نصف قيمته بس لما تروح تشوف
لنا النوادي اغلبها شركات مدرجه سوق
الاسهم ولو تشوف يوفنتوس كم باع مو بس
قمصان قمصان وجميع المنتجات دايز اللي
عليها او فيها اي رخصه اللي شعار يوفنتوس
في السنه كلها كانت 40 او 45 مليون يورو
يعني وهم يقولون 60 مليون في السنه كلها
هذا على كل المنتجاتهم 40 مليون يورو يعني
نادي كويس
مهما كذبوا هم جابوا رقم مبيعات القمصان
اللي انباعت في المحلات لكن في الغالب
المحل له كات او له نسبه بعدين العقد اصلا
مع شركه زينات
ويعطون رسوم معينه نسبه للنادي فالغالب
رسوم يصير سبعه ونص الى 10% يمكن قالت خبر
من فتره على نادي ليفربول كانوا اخذوا
صفقه قياسيه 20% من المبيعات تروح لهم لكن
الخال بسبعه الى 10%
بالنسبه الكبيره هذه تروح همم همم عده
جهاز بشكل رئيسي اللي هناك او اديداس او
الى همم باقي الشركات والبصيده تروح
للنادي وحتى النسبه هذه ما تتربح يراد من
الاراده النادي نادي يوفنتوس في الفتره
اللي كان فيها همم رونالدو نهايه السنه
خسرا خسران بالملايين يعني ونفس الخبر
تكرر بعدها بسنه يمران
مانشستر يونايتد والخبر كان اكبر بعد كان
200 مليون المبيعات في اسبوع همم تروح
تشوف مبيعات يونايتد في السنه كلها 90
مليون يعني لكل برضه افضل النوادي اذا كان
الافضل في التسويق في غير صحيح همم
الارقام هذه طب بس هل اصلا المفروض الواحد
يبرر لانه كره القدم كرياضه خاصه
الاوروبيه ما في احد يحقق ارباح
كرب نهايه السنه كثير منها شركات مدرجه
غلبه خسرانه
وتشتغل بي خلينا نقول بطريقتين
يا اما النسبه من الخساره تقبلها للملاك
انهم يرفعون قيمه النادي وممكن يبيعونا
بربح مستقبله
فهذا يعني اسلوب وفي طريقه ثانيه همم انه
لا احنا مثلا زي قطر او ابو ظبي او نشتري
نادي وننفق فيه ويكون جزء من همم جزء منه
وصول الى جمهور مختلف وبنحط عليه مثلا
شركه الطيران او همم نكون علاقات والناس
تعرفنا يعني يكون الهدف منه تسويق اكثر
همم احنا شفنا مثلا الارقام اخر 20 سنه
ارقام قياسيه لرعايه زي اذربيجان اذربيجان
الغاز وصار عندهم دخل في الفينينات وكان
يبغون يعني يسوقون نفسهم همم
للرعايه وتشوفهم على كثير
فهو اسلوب موجود طيب بنتكلم هذا استثماري
غير مباراه بس لا يمكن عوايد اقتصاديه
اخرى همم همم هل في تبرير اقتصادي
وممكن ممكن
همم يمكن الناس شويه ما تستوعب قديش انا
مكلف انك تبني جراند تبني الاسد تجاري جدا
مكلف
فشوفون مثلا علامات تجاريه معروفه همم
وقيمتها السوقيه 50% مليار 100 مليار 200
مليار اا وتوقعون الارقام هذه انها بس لا
هذه ارقام فعليه تقييم همم الشركه بناتها
على عشرات السنوات سواء من تسويق مباشر
تدفع فيه او من سمعه المنتجات او من الناس
يعني مرتبط فيهم
فالدوله اذا تبغى مثلا تفتح اسواق
الاستثمار او للسياحه او تبغى تحصل على
انتباه وتحصل على ثقه الناس لو لو تسوي
اعلانات بطريقه تقليديه خلينا نقول مثلا
تشتري
لوحات طرق واعلانات في التلفزيون والى
اخره
مليار مليار ما راح اسوي شيء
يعني مبالغ هذه بتروح في في اسابيع قليله
يعني وراحت همم اعلان السوبر بول الامريكي
كانت 30 ثانيه 5,000,000$
فيعني صعب جدا انك تحصل على انتباه
وقضيه اخرى
الدول مو زي الشركه الشركات ممكن ااا مثلا
طلعت اعلان في تويتر او في سناب شات اشترى
منتج فلاني انت عارف المنتج بس يذكرك فيه
اغلب التسويق تذكير انك تشتري بس الدول
يعني لها علاقه بالصوره الذهنيه والصوره
الذهنيه مره صعب انها تتغير همم انا
اشوفها دبي لانه ما شاء الله دبي يعني من
زمان انها حقت يعني وجود همم غير طبيعي
عالميا لكن
معه وجودكم قوي همم في نزله زي المسلسل
همم زي همم التلفزيون
فشوف اتابعني فؤاد
يتكلمون عنه يتكلمون عنه ومعنهم يعني
اشخاص في امريكا مشاهير عندهم فلوس يعني
يقدرون يسافرون يعرفون قد سمعوا عن دبي
لكن ما قد شافوا احد بس يمكن عن النت فلكس
وكان يعني تلفزيون
انه والله زينا عند مدينه زينا والعكس
عنده اشياء حلوه وشيء جديده واشوف الناس
كيف عايشه نفسه اسلوب الحياه اللي احنا
نبغاه
فكم اخذت دبي عشان توصل همم
للموقع اللي فيه 20 30 سنه في اكيد سووا
في رعايات في مبالغ دفعت همم بس برضه
الوقت نفسه والاستثمار والتجربه الناس
اللي جاءوا على مدى سنين
هل انه هذا الشيء مثلا بنحل بدعه رونالدو
او انهم مثلا ميسي برضو كان سفير همم
ان شاء الله في التسويق كثير بس ك- كعادي
اقتصادي انا بس افهمها ان محاوله همم انك
بتغير صوره ثانيه واستثمار بعيد المدرسه
يعني ممكن بعد فتره يروح عنده وتنسى الناس
رونالدو عامه الناس بعد سنوات لكن همم
لازال الحديث عنك موجود
انه كيف بدا الانتباه للدوره اذا اخذنا
هذا على شكل بس لوجينا نتكلم على شكل
كوره شويه
اللي هو كاس العالم
دولار
لسمامه
وتلقى كل دوله نفس الشيء لما تصرف مبلغ
بالمليارات الاستضافه كاس العالم مع ولا
دوري اسبانيا البرازيل ولا
جنوب افريقيا ولا غيره انها قدره النهار
روسيه انها تعيد الاستثمار
في كل سنه سنه
في افريقيا
ها واحد بس في دول غنيه زي همم الدلم
ماركو شمال اوروبا والمانيا وحتى فرنسا
الى حد كبير وفي دول زي البرتغال وزي همم
اليونان
اا فكان يبغوني يبينون انه ترى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا مقبل على تغيير وانه همم
الثروات اللي موجوده في الدول الغنيه راح
يعني تنتقل للسيد من الدول الجديده لانه
الاولمبياد صار
صرفوا على بني تحتيه زي اللي سوت القطار
ما هو نفس من مبالغ لكن نفس الفكره انه
بنى القطارات
[موسيقى]
يعني بني تحتيه منها ملاعب جديده
واستضافه الالعاب انجحت وقتها
بس اللي صار خلال اشهر قليله فاضيه
فقط
حاولوا تخلصهم منها بعض الاشياء قفلوها
بعض الاشياء طلع عليها الزرع اهله
والى 2008 قلت الاسم الماليه
الديون اللي تكملتها
نتكلم على مثلا الصرف على التقاعد وعلى
البدلات اللي كان يعطونها وعدم تكسير
الضرائب مشاكل واجد
لكن
البليارات اللي صرفوها اكيد ما رجعوها طيب
هل في طريقه علميه ندرس الاثر اقتصادي في
ناس حاولوا في اوراق بحثيه طلعت كم
التاثير على الناتج المحلي من استضافه حدث
كاس العالم اولمبياد مشابهه في الحجم
الاغلب ما في فائده ايجابي همم
لندن 2012 همم
هل جابت سياحه بعدها ارقام كثير تقول اول
سنه بعد الاولمبياد قالت السياحه في لندن
مع انه الصرف على البنيه التحتيه كان اقل
بكثير من اي دوله اخرى لان اغلب مكان
موجود
بس احنا نتكلم على على
يعني اثر اقتصادي تقدر تحسبه
هل في اثر غير محسوب
صعب انك تحكم لانه حتى اذا اذا ضمينا بعض
الاثار الاقتصاديه لماذا نحسبها همم اتوقع
اعلى نسبه قريتها نصف%
ارتفاع الناتج المحلي لمده سته شهور هذا
الاثر
بصراحه
امريكا 94 كاس العالم
امريكا صرفت على كاس العالم
على على كاس العالم في روسيا همم حوالي 25
كان 50 افريقيا
لانه موجوده همم بس هل مثلا خلت همم كاس
العالم عفوا كره القدم لامريكا بعد كاس
العالم ااه دخل دخلت الكوره همم بدت
النوادي تطلع في امريكا تمام يمكن حتى
الانديه اللي كانت موجوده
لكره القدم في اوروبا
خلص يعني تجربتها في اوروبا امريكا همم
نادي الكره في امريكا
اكيد
يعني
بدات في بيئه اصلا الرياضات للربح كره
السله كره القدم جدا
يعني هذا الشيء حتى الاقتصاديين يمكن
يعرضونا شوي يعرضون انه في دعم حكومي لبعض
الانديه
فمثلا كره القدم الامريكيه رياضه شعبيه
شعبيه
همم انه ابنه يعني استديو استاذ رياضه
جديد واحنا بنستاجر منكم يعني بس انتم
اللي تكفلوا فيه ولا تراه نطلع برا
المدينه النادي خاص
فسكان المدينه يضغطون على البلديه انه لا
ابنه هذا النادي حقنا كيف يروح في نوادي
انتقلت
في يصرفون صرف ضخم على على الاستاد
الرياضي من الضرائب همم وفي الاخير ما في
عائد من الاجار يخطط لكن انه الضغط الناس
رغبتهم في الاخير هم اللي همم فهذا جزء من
بعض الربحيه لكن في نوادي كثيره لا مربحه
او في استثمارات في مليار يطلعوا من من
القطاع همم الرياضه تحديدا
ها هم يدخلون الاداريه بس حاليا
[ضحك]
الثانيه على الجيم
مع انه القيمه لا يعني انها يعني ثابته
اي سي ميلان
2008 10 كان من اغلى النواتج اللي موجوده
انباع بمبلغ بسيط قبل كم سنه ويعاني من
مشاكل ماليه القيمه على وضعه الحالي طبعا
اذا استمر بادائه وتنبيعه بنفس الاداء
ممكن تجيب مبلغ من القيمه في الاخير هو
تقييم همم متى ما يتحقق انه اذا احد شرى
اذا ما احد شراب معناه انه الرقم مجرد
الورق فنشوف تقيمه الشركات في شركات طلعت
مليارات همم 10000 مليارات وقت ال220
همم بس السوق طاح القيمه هذه